it's estimated that there's 7 trillion
of them in Alaska alone
yeah that's right Alaska due to global
warming and ocean temperatures Rising
mosquitoes can live in places like this
there's a number of ways we could get
rid of them
bats eat mosquitoes without any risks
they can eat 600 mosquitoes in an hour
so if we had enough bats in theory they
could effectively wipe out mosquitoes
all around the world
but then how would we get rid of the
billions of bats in the sky instead of
these options we may need to release
genetically modified male mosquitoes
ones that don't bite and can only
produce sterile Offspring it could take
several decades but with enough of our
genetically modified mosquitoes
producing sterile Offspring mosquitoes
would eventually be eradicated